hey wisecrack Jared here and today we're
talking about the happiest show in the
Netflix catalog Bojack horseman with its
colorful animation talking animals and
Hollywood glamour
Bojack might look like your typical
happy-go-lucky cartoon but this is far
from the case the show's light-hearted
veneer hides a dark and downright
depressing reality which is fitting
given its focus on the disillusionment
that inevitably comes when you look
beneath the surface
Bojack reveals the ugly narcissistic
reality that lies behind the dazzling
facade of Hollywood most important thing
is you gotta give the people what they
want even if it kills you even if it
empties you out until there's nothing
left to empty from mr. peanut butters
feigned interest I want to talk to you
Erica to studio executives only focused
on money to meaningless award ceremonies
that only reward those with established
names in other words Hollywood's a real
pretty town that's smack on top of all
that black tar by the time you realize
you're sinking it's too late but the
show goes far deeper Hollywood could be
considered a metaphor for existence in
general just like the facade of hollywoo
covers up the reality of an ugly hollow
industry the trappings of our daily
lives cover up the meaninglessness of
existence itself this idea known as
existential nihilism is foundational to
Bojack horseman if life is truly
meaningless then how are we supposed to
deal with it welcome to this wives crack
edition on the philosophy of Bojack
horseman what does it know does it know
things let's find out but before we dive
in this wisecrack edition is sponsored
by best fiends and the newest game in
the best fiends trilogy best fiends
forever it's the same characters and
story as before but a totally different
kind of game an addicted clicker
adventure where you slap collect and
love luck pretty much everything while
trying to get as far as you can as fast
as you can also something we really like
in addition to making crazy addictive
games like this best fiends gives back
as a supporter of the charity Oceana
helping protect the world's oceans so be
sure to check out the new best fiends
games it's free and you can download it
from the link below let us know how far
you get and thanks again to best fiends
for sponsoring this video part 1
distract yourself a key way to cope with
the anguish of a meaningless world is to
simply distract yourself I just wanted
to do something light and fun
to distract me from the deep well of
sadness that is my life
princess Carolyn persistently distracts
herself with her job and her compulsive
need to fix the life of those she cares
about
despite complaining about work
dominating her life she can't actually
handle the free time that comes without
it are you gonna head out soon where
else would I go when her agency folds
she finally has time for the
relationship she always wanted but still
finds a way to get right back to the
Hollywood rhinestone I think I'm having
an epiphany I'm gonna be a manager Todd
bow Jack's best friend and perpetual
mooch is happy so long as he has
something to do but ray a task the one
time we do see Todd without anything to
do he immediately starts to spiral into
existential despair I need something to
do a job or a task or a direction in
life to have a purpose before finding
something to take his mind off it Todd
may not have much direction or common
sense but he manages to keep himself
busy he composes a space opera builds
his own Disneyland and starts a number
of businesses an old Hallows Eve stool
in January how fiendishly drove
similarly mr. peanut butter spends his
life in a constant state of distraction
though he may seem like a [ __ ]
he's so stupid he doesn't realize how
miserable he should be mr. peanut butter
is more self-aware than most the
universe is a cruel uncaring void the
key to being happy isn't the search for
meaning it's to just keep yourself busy
with unimportant nonsense and eventually
you'll be dead and then there's Bojack
bojack's whole life is a series of
distractions the way Bojack spends his
days is so trivial that the show often
makes a joke of not showing us what he's
doing half the time yeah two days I can
do all those things
oh [ __ ] I didn't do any of those things
in fact in the years since horsing
around
Bojack has been able to drift through
life in your constant state of
distraction horsing around
that ended eleven years ago really where
does the time go but in the first
episode Bojack has a mild anxiety attack
that sends him to the hospital the
doctor tells him he needs to take it
easier take it easy
are you kidding he doesn't have a job he
has no real responsibilities he doesn't
do anything but take it easy the show
asks a question commonly directed at
celebrities they have everything so how
could they not be happy great house
great career great life that must be why
I'm so goddamn happy all the time this
question was addressed by 17th century
philosopher Blaise Pascal who was
considered by many to be a precursor to
the existentialist for Pascal when given
too much time to think humans will
eventually contemplate their own
insignificance which inevitably bums
them out or as Pascal puts it I have
discovered that all the unhappiness of
men arises from one single fact that
they cannot stay quietly in their own
chamber I have found that there is one
very real reason namely the natural
poverty of our feeble and mortal
condition so miserable that nothing can
comfort us when we think of it closely
for Pascal humans have a natural
psychological defense mechanism that
keeps these thoughts at bay were really
easily distracted and when we're
distracted we stop thinking about our
existence and can be if not happy at
least functional Pascal directly
addresses the unhappy celebrity question
though he uses kings instead of movie
stars yet when we imagine a king
intended with every pleasure he can feel
if he be without diversion and be left
to consider and reflect on what he is
this feeble happiness will not sustain
him like a king Bojack has no serious
struggle to occupy his life instead he
has to spend all of his time trying to
distract himself so that he never has to
think about the reality of his situation
although he succeeds in doing this for
years the whole charade comes crashing
down when he reads Diane's book
one-trick pony in the book Bojack sees
an honest reflection of himself warts
and all he is forced to face all the
things he really is and isn't and to
confront the extent of his
self-deception I love the part about how
you became famous so you could be
constantly surrounded by distraction who
wouldn't have to be alone with yourself
so what should Bojack do now that his
distraction has
for Pascal once you've passed the
critical point where diversion will no
longer sustain you the only recourse is
to turn to God but for Bojack this isn't
an option
it seems that hollywoo is a post god is
dead world in the christmas special the
show uses Santa Claus as a stand-in to
discuss the non-existence of God he's a
lie that grown-ups made up because we
like to believe that there's an order to
the universe and that good behavior will
lead to happiness but the fact is that
just isn't true but if there's no God
where are we supposed to turn for Bojack
the first choice is right back to
distraction the show provides two
separate case studies of what happens
when you try to force distraction after
the illusion has been broken and neither
ends well first Secretariat gives a
young Bojack advice that basically
amounts to don't think about it Bojack
when you get sad you run straight ahead
and you keep running forward no matter
what there are people in your life who
are gonna try to hold you back slow you
down but you don't let them don't you
stop running and don't you ever look
behind you there's nothing for you
behind you all that exists is what's
ahead but once he's disqualified from
racing and can no longer keep the
thoughts at bay
you could be the fastest runner in the
world but you can't the second case is
Sara Lynn Bojack drag Sara Lynn on a
month-long bender that only ends when
she ODS on well Bojack the heroin not
the horse looking back on it that might
have been a bit on the nose if trying to
reclaim his distracted state is doomed
to end in tragedy what other options
does Bojack have part two radical
freedom from the beginning Bojack
rejects responsibility I'm responsible
for my own happiness I can't even be
responsible for my own breakfast he
wants to escape the realities of his own
terrible life choices I didn't do
anything wrong because I can't do
anything after his first bender Bojack
asks Diane am I just doomed to be the
person that I am look at the person in
that book I know that I can be selfish
narcissistic and self-destructive but
underneath all that deep down I'm a good
person and I need you to tell me that
I'm good
Bojack is afraid of what 20th century
French philosopher jean-paul Sartre
called radical freedom which was a major
focus of his philosophy existentialism I
stand
my critique of sastra his philosophical
arguments helped many tyrannical regimes
justify overt cruelty also the French
smell and I hate them if existentialism
had a catchphrase it would be existence
precedes essence and objects essence for
Sartre can be thought of as its purpose
if I make a hammer I create it with a
particular purpose in mind
ie hammer so we would say that the
hammers essence precedes its existence
for a Christian a human is like a hammer
a tool created by God with a purpose in
mind but for an existential nihilist
humans and horsemen exist just because
unlike a hammer or a gentle Farms
chicken there's no purpose underlying
bojack's existence and nothing that he's
meant to do there's nothing stopping
Bojack from stealing the D from the
Hollywood sign or doing three months
worth of drugs and on the flip side
there's nothing forcing him to do those
things either
Bojack has total control over every
choice he makes this is what Sartre
meant by radical freedom and it's
definitely not supposed to be comforting
that is what I mean when I say that man
is condemned to be free condemned
because he did not create himself yet is
nevertheless at liberty and from the
moment that he is thrown into this world
he's responsible for everything he does
or as Diane and Bojack put it that's the
thing I don't think I believe in deep
down I kind of think all you are is just
the things that you do well that's
depressing
there is no good Bojack deep down there
was only the one Bojack and he is
entirely defined by the choices he's
made so far or as Todd puts it the bow
Jack at the end of season three you are
all the things that are wrong with you
while this may not seem too comforting
it does offer Bojack one bit of hope yes
that means bow Jack is defined by the
choices he's made so far but he's not
doomed to be the person in that book
forever he has the freedom to change his
actions and himself but it's entirely up
to him to do so it's never too late to
be the person you want to be you need to
choose the life you won the show
provides the optimistic take on start by
using water as a metaphor for bojack's
radical freedom Bojack often finds
himself overwhelmed by water but at the
end of the underwater episode in season
3 after falling from the ledge of the
taffy factory bow Jack finally
recognizes the water for what it is not
overwhelming and scary force but instead
a medium of incredible opportunity part
three embraced the absurd when mr.
peanut butters brother gets sick he goes
through his own existential crisis come
to work clock in he puts sugar in your
coffee watch it slowly disappear into
nothingness but his sugar doesn't know
why sugar didn't ask to be born but he
doesn't suffer through it for very long
I realized something today when my
brother called from the hospital and I
think it's gonna make you feel a lot
better what what is it none of this
matters
Bojack gets similar advice from his old
writing partner and Harvard alum cuddly
whiskers who abandon his Hollywood life
the nos cure is meaningless it's all
meaningless and is finally able to find
happiness only after you give up
everything can you begin to find a way
to be happy mr. peanut butter and cuddly
whiskers past the happiness after or
even because of the realization of
nihilism invokes the 20th century French
thinker Albert Camus and his philosophy
of absurdism for Camus the universe is
irrational and meaningless and yet
humans are desperate to find reason and
meaning in it and he calls this
discrepancy the absurd once you become
aware of the absurd you only have three
choices return to the cycle of daily
life and don't think about it commit
suicide or his preferred option
rebellion ie accept the absurd and be
happy anyway because screw the universe
for thinking it can control how you feel
Camus illustrates these ideas in his
essay the myth of Sisyphus about a man
who is doomed to push a rock up a hill
each day only to watch it roll back down
again
Sisyphus becomes cow Moos absurd hero
when he recognizes the absurdity of his
task but decides to be happy in spite of
it the show directly references the myth
of Sisyphus I have to push a boulder up
the hill and then have it roll over me
time and time again there's also the
recurring symbol of the baboon jogging
up the hill outside bojack's house every
day he's running up that same Hill it
gets easier huh every day it gets a
little easier yeah but you got to do it
every day
that's the hard part at the end of
season three Bojack comes face to face
with the meaningless loop of his life in
the young actress from ethan around I
wanted to be like you like me
wanna be famous no no it happens that
the stage set collapses at the end of
the awakening comes in time the
consequence suicide or recovery just as
Camus describes Bojack runs out of the
stage set and begins to drive into
nowhere driving has repeatedly served as
a way for Bojack to try and escape the
absurd may be his own take on
Secretariat's advice to run and don't
look back but when he releases the
steering wheel Bojack gives in
submitting himself to the absurd and to
suicide however when he sees the wild
horses they represent for him the
alternative embraced the absurd carry
out your meaningless task and be happy
in spite of it they may be seen as
absurd heroes a group of horses who have
embraced running purely for its own sake
like Sisyphus they run carry out the
meaningless tasks and are happy anyway
Bojack has proven himself willing to
give everything up maybe he's ready to
follow cuddly whiskers advice and
finally start to become happy conclusion
the show does offer one possible
solution to bojack's struggle for
meaning family it's weird if you don't
have a family with your career sure when
you pay attention to all the times
Bojack watches horsing around the scenes
all revolve around the in show family
I've learned that when you're in the
loving family there's nothing wrong with
a little horsing around during the first
big bender he has a vision of himself as
a simple family man bojack's attempt to
sleep with penny at the end of season 2
illustrates how desperate he is to start
over and choose the domestic life he
could have had with Charlotte the wild
horses may represent more than just the
absurd hero they may also represent the
herd and a sense of belonging that
Bojack lacks and with the teaser at the
end of season 3 it seems the show is
preparing to explore this theme of
family much more though I hope it works
out for him something tells me that even
family won't be able to fill the void
hey guys as always thanks for watching
real quick if you're looking for another
cool channel that explores your favorite
movies TV shows and video games then go
check out looper from fun movie lists to
hidden Easter eggs
looper releases addictive new videos
every day of the week click here to
visit their channel page and subscribe
and if you've got cartoons on the mind
go check out their video on the
troupe of South Park so go subscribe to
looper and tell them wisecrack cinch and
finally if you're interested in another
cartoon about the ramifications of a
godless universe click on this plum vez
to check out our video on the philosophy
of Rick and Morty Wubba lubba dub dub
alright enough for me I've got another
purge video to work on thanks a lot guys
peace
Oh